but again apologies for starting late
okay as you all know the president has
long talked about our nation being at an
inflection point
he has been clear democracy is under
assault and we cannot pretend otherwise
the president will continue to call
attention to the threat to democratic
integrity and to Public Safety posed by
those who deny the documented truth
about election result and those who seek
to undermine public faith in our system
of government
unfortunately we have seen mega mega
Republican officials who don't believe
in the rule of law
they refuse to accept the results of
free and fair elections and they fan the
Flames of political violence through
what they praise and what they refuse to
condemn
it remains important for the president
to State strongly and unequivocally that
violence has no place in our democracy
he believes other leaders of both
parties on both sides
have a responsibility to communicate
this very clearly as well
the president has been emphatic and
optimistic that Americans care about
protecting our democracy he has
consistently talked about the fact that
America has emerged stronger from some
of our darkest moments
and today there are far more Americans
of every background and every belief who
reject the dangerous path of political
violence then accept it
the president will continue to speak
about the challenges facing our
democracy and his enduring belief that
America will persevere
he'll also keep acting to address
political violence including by
continued implementation of the first
ever National strategy for countering
domestic terrorism that he released in
June of 2021.
now President Biden has made it his top
economic priority to lower costs for
American families and he has been
delivering
he's beaten beaten big Pharma and
Medicare is negotiating lower lower
prescription drug prices as well gas
prices have come down by a buck 25 per
gallon since June and medicare premiums
are down as well yesterday was our first
day of open enrollment set season thanks
to the inflation reduction act which
Congressional Republicans want to repeal
that's the first thing that they want to
do four out of five consumers can find a
plan that costs ten dollars or less a
month
additionally 13 million Americans will
continue to save an average of 800 bucks
a year on coverage and today we're
announcing additional actions to lower
food and heating costs for American
families the vice president will be in
Boston this evening to announce that
we're making billions of dollars
available this winter to help bring down
home heating bills for low-income
families all across the country we're
also making nearly nine billion billion
dollars through the inflation reduction
act available to States and tribes to
help families make their homes more
energy efficient and the Department of
Agriculture is helping bring down food
prices at the grocery store through new
measures to expand meat and poultry
processing capacity altogether these
actions and others will provide families
a little extra breathing room you hear
the president say that often and they
are in stark contrast to the plans
republicans in Congress have cooped up
to drive up costs Congressional
Republicans want to repeal the inflation
reduction act which gives us the ability
to lower drug prices and that utility
CEOs have said will bring monthly energy
bills down
they oppose the release of oil from
reserves which multiple industry
analysts have said is helping bring
prices down at the pump they're going to
bat for Big Oil even as they pad the
pockets of shareholders and keep gas
prices up for American families they
want to raise the age of Social Security
benefits and put the program
the program that so many people work so
hard for alongside Medicare on the
chopping block and they want to restore
disastrous tax cuts for the rich the
bottom line is the president is
committed to helping families right now
while Republicans officials are
committed to raising costs and chilling
for a big farmer and Big Oil
lastly
this afternoon in a few minutes the
president will take part in the
culminating event for the talent
pipeline challenge which brings together
more than 300 Partners to expand
Workforce Development for jobs created
by bipartisan infrastructure law along
with the chips and science act inflation
reduction Act and the American Rescue
plan
the event comes amid a Resurgence of
American infrastructure projects and
Manufacturing driven by the president's
economic agenda the bipartisan
infrastructure law chips and science act
and inflation reduction act will create
millions of good paying jobs and the
challenge is helping create Pathways for
all Americans to fill those jobs
at today's event the White House will
host CEOs Union presidents Community
College presidents philanthropic
philanthropic leaders and others who
have made commitments to this very
challenge with that
something you want to kick us off
some quick topics um on this speech
tonight can you discuss why the speech
is a considered a political event that's
being organized by the DNC versus the
similar speech in Philadelphia which was
an official White House Event yeah
that's a good question look we're less
than a week away a week out as you all
know from the midterms election I do
want to be careful about talking about
elections here from this Podium we do uh
believe in the rule of law in this
Administration and so what we are seeing
as I just mentioned in my topper an
alarming number of Republican officials
suggests they will not accept the
results of of this election so we are
also we've also seen a recent political
violence that is similarly alarming
disturbing and that rhetoric continues
the president believes that it is a
moment of Reckoning this is not a
regular moment in our democracy this is
not a regular moment in time and this is
as the president has said many times we
are in an inflection point and he's
going to call it all out like he did in
very direct terms and he talked about it
just last night in front of 3 000 people
in southern in Southern Florida so
you'll hear from him I'm not going to
get ahead of the president but this is
why uh we we see this as an important
moment tonight and on Elon Musk and
Twitter
um I'm wondering what impact the White
House believes that his takeover Twitter
is having on political discourse at this
point and also whether the White House
would actually pay eight dollars a month
to make sure his accounts were verified
so I on your first question
um so look I don't believe it's it's a
an issue that made it to the president's
desk yet it's not a conversation that
the president uh uh uh has uh is is
aware of as you know we're focused on
many things uh including this evening
but clearly we will let you know if
anything changes and certainly uh give
you all an update what about on the
second what was the wait can you say the
second question again was it about if
they pay eight dollars a month soon well
I know I just answered that that
particular thing you know that's
something for the president that we need
to talk to the president about certainly
has not come across his desk and so as
soon if anything changes on that we
certainly will share that information
go ahead you mentioned we're less than a
week out a logistical question what does
the president plan to do on Election
night will he be here monitoring results
that's a good question um we will share
more when we we have that uh I don't
have anything about his schedule about
him traveling but certainly we will we
will certainly share more of what his
day will look like uh on on um on
November 8th next Tuesday less than a
week away
you have said that the president will
deliver remarks after the election the
day after should we expect some kind of
formal remarks or did you just mean that
he will find some kind of way to to
weigh in well I'm saying that uh you'll
certainly hear from the president he
will give remarks I don't know yet what
it will look like but certainly you'll
hear from the president the day after
the election
question I know you guys always ask me
this well when I don't want to get ahead
of uh ahead of it but you will we we
will uh you will certainly hear from the
president after after
thanks Karine along those lines in this
final stretch the president is traveling
to California Chicago New York Maryland
aren't these pretty safe Democratic
strongholds why would those be his
destinations
New Mexico right New Mexico tomorrow
he's going to Philly on uh on uh
oh my gosh these days on Saturday so he
will be out there if there's more travel
to share we certainly will share them
but look the president it's not just I
know you're talking about the last
couple of days but the president has
been out on the road non-stop I know I
am I am very tired we got in pretty late
last night uh so uh and I've done many
of the trips with him and he has been
Non-Stop and he'll continue to do that
we will certainly have more uh travel to
share uh in the upcoming days and uh
you'll see you'll see what will he'll be
going but Maryland for example where
he'll be campaigning with Wes Moore I
mean Paul's show more uh beating his
opponent two to one at this point why
does he need the president's house so
I'm going to be really careful about
getting into any kind of uh punditry
from here political politics from here
um but look the president believes uh
this isn't a more important time uh
there is uh the American public has a
choice there is a choice in front of
them and there are many places to have
those conversation and lay that out for
the American people and that choice is
very clear do you want a a congressional
Democrats and a president that's working
every day to deliver for the American
people or do you want uh Congressional
Republicans who are doing the complete
opposite who want to increase in energy
costs we want to increase your health
care premiums and we feel that there are
many places where he can have that
conversation there are many places where
it's going to be important for the
American people to hear directly from
the president of the United States but
let's not forget he's going to New
Mexico tomorrow he's going to
Pennsylvania as you all know he's been
to Pennsylvania a few times he was just
in Florida in front of 3 000 people last
night and uh and uh which was an
important important conversation and an
event to have I want to be very careful
here and not to get into again into
politics or elections so I'm going to
leave it there without
again we believe in the rule of laws we
want to be careful go ahead
um the White House removed until we
talked about the increase in Social
Security benefits in 2023 uh through
President Biden's leadership there was a
contextual note I'm not sure that the
proper terminology is for the platform
that was added to that was it removed
because of the addition of the note or
was it removed because of the concern
about the veracity of the message so it
was I look the Tweet was not complete
usually when we put out a tweet we
posted with contacts and it did not have
that context so in the past we've
pointed out that for the first time in
our in over a decade seniors medicare
premiums will will decrease even as
their Social Security checks increase
that's a little bit of context that was
not included this means that seniors
will have a chance to get ahead of
inflation due to the rare combination of
rising benefits and falling premiums and
let's not forget as as you've been
hearing me say for the past few minutes
about Mega republicans in Congress
Congress in their continued threat to
threaten Social Security and Medicare
proposing proposing to them on the chop
proposing to put them on the chopping
blocks every five years threatening
benefits and to change eligibility so
those are the types of contacts that
would normally be with the Tweet like
that it did not it did not have that
contest it was an incomplete tweet as I
just mentioned and so that's why you saw
the digital team take that action and I
think part of the reason I asked the
president mentioned a similar type of
thing in both of his events yesterday
saying on my watch in one case on our
watch and the other case I included the
Medicare piece of this that you're
talking about back end you believe that
as long as the Medicare piece is
included that's not claiming credit for
something that is quite literally tied
to We believe that if we we want to lay
the we want to lay our argument out
fully and that was important to do as we
uh as we put out you know information
like that or as we put out a tweet and
that was an incomplete tweet so we do
think it is important to do
um create just the White House think
that another rate hike from the FED will
be positive for the economy or negative
so as you know and you heard you hear us
say this many times uh the FED is uh is
independent it's an independent agency
and we believe uh the president believes
that it has uh this it has the best
monetary policies to address uh
inflation and they and they are also uh
the chairman uh chair Powell is is
committed uh to that uh to that to that
very kind of charge that is ahead of
them I don't want to don't want to
comment on it I I know they might be the
meeting may be happening right now as
I'm standing in front of you so don't
want to get ahead of it is not something
that we comment from here about as you
know on a separate issue does the White
House have a reaction to newly disclosed
emails showing that former president
Trump's attorneys saw Supreme Court
Justice Clarence Thomas as their best
hope for a returning 2015. so I saw
those reports right before I walked out
to the podium and my understanding is
that those emails are being reviewed by
the January 6 committee as we know the
January 6 committee is doing incredibly
important work to get to the bottom of
what happened on January 6 which as you
heard the president say was one of our
darkest days in our nation's history was
a as we all know and we all saw and you
all reported an attack on our democracy
so we will defer to the committee on
this investigation I don't want to get
ahead of that but I as far as I know I
understand they are reviewing the emails
to what degree could you characterize
how much the Pelosi attack influenced
the president's decision to give this
address tonight uh how much of a
catalyst is that and kind of as a
related question has the president made
any personal Outreach or considered
making personal Outreach to Republican
leaders to ask them for a more forceful
response to condemn that attack other
violence I understand the power of the
bully pulpit tonight but has he done any
direct contact to Republican leaders and
I appreciate your question and I
understand your question I'm going to
start with the last one first
it should not be controversial to speak
out against political violence uh it
should be something as political as
political leaders should automatically
do in a forceful way and you all have
reported on what happened uh to Paul
Pelosi and how horrific it was and how
devastating it was and how dangerous uh
that action was uh and the rhetoric that
we're seeing that rise of rhetoric that
we are seeing uh you know you have
people out there who listen and who take
that rhetoric very seriously and so the
president believes that it shouldn't
have to he he shouldn't have to call
them to say hey you need to condemn
condemn what happened a little more
forcefully that is something that it
should just be something that's
automatic and they should just do that
look the president again is making the
speech because we're seeing an alarming
number of Republican Republican
officials who are saying they're being
very clear they're not going to accept
the results of these elections that's a
problem and yes when we see what
happened to uh Paul Pelosi and again the
president spoke you all know you've
heard you've heard us you've heard us
say this that spread and spoke to the
speaker on Friday he spoke very
forcefully at his event Friday after
Friday evening he spoke to this again on
Saturday and just yesterday in Florida
he spoke in front in front of a Florida
Floridians about this this attack and so
uh look he he's going to continue to
call this out what we're seeing is is a
attack on our democracy and the
president has been very clear we need to
protect our democracy we need to
strengthen our democracy and he feels it
is important as the President of the
United States to continue uh to speak to
this
let me ask you a big picture question
does the president believe that if the
country chooses divided government next
week and gives Republicans control of
the house and the federal government can
operate efficiently and effectively
while he's still president so look I
don't want to get into hypotheticals I
know you're you want me to answer to a
potential result that we might see next
week so I want to be very careful here
what I can say is that he believes and I
said this at the top and I'll repeat it
here that there are far more Americans
of every background and belief who
reject the dangerous path of political
violence than accepted we see this in
polling we see that majority of
Americans do not do want want to protect
our democracy and do not do not agree
with the political violence do not agree
with the rise of rhetoric that we are
seeing and so I'll leave it there that's
what we're seeing from from Americans a
majority of Americans I'm just not going
to get into hypotheticals from here you
need a speech yesterday in Florida the
president uh suggested that shutdowns in
default are likely outcomes if the
Republicans take control of the House of
Representatives if he doesn't agree with
their demands on Social Security and
Medicare to what extent should Americans
be braced for those out there I mean the
president is saying that because
Republicans are saying that republicans
in Congress have been very very clear
that if uh if they do not get put
Medicare and Social Security on The
Chopping Block right you have one
Senator that suggested five years at
another senator from Wisconsin who
suggested we should put it in the
chopping box every year and they said if
they don't get those demands if they are
not able to do that then they're going
to put our economy at risk they're going
to put it into a spiral downturn that's
what they said they're going to do and
again this goes into what the president
has been saying there's a clear choice
for the American public there is a stark
choice for the American public this is
what the president has been talking
about almost every day for the past
several months so again not going to get
into hypotheticals but we should take
them by their word right we should this
is what they're saying that they're
going to do yeah JJ uh the news just
broke the FED did raise rates by the 75
basis points just following up to see if
you did want to share anything now that
the news said
this happens to me all the time up here
uh okay so um I'll say a couple of
things again you know we see this
presidency our view is that the federal
uh the FED uh is a independent agency
and we respect their independence uh the
FED actions help bring inflation down
and as mortgage rates increase demand in
the housing market should continue to
cool and inventory should increase which
should have the effect of lowering
housing inflation this part of our
transition this is part of our
transition to stable and more stable and
steady growth as you hear us speak about
uh from our economic team and from also
for myself and from the president and
again stable stable and steady growth
with lower inflation this is the kind of
economy that deliver for working
families and that's how we see the work
of the of the fed I'm not going to go
into any specifics any more details from
here and then one other thing on
violence political violence but do you
know if the president has had his head
is to speak directly to Paul Pelosi yet
I don't have any calls to read out on a
direct conversation that he's had uh
with Paul Pelosi as you know he spoken
to the speaker uh on Friday and you know
he continues to keep them in their
prayers and he is he is glad to hear
that Paul Pelosi will have a full
recovery
um and I'll just leave it as that for
now go ahead too yeah I just wanted to
go back to Kelly's first question
um was the attack on Paul Pelosi
um an impetus for this speech to happen
was an inspiration and the president
already been working on it what's the
timeline so just a little just just to
to share you know this is something that
the president has talked about for some
time right this is nothing this isn't
new for this president he's talked about
we all know about the soul of a nation
and how he decided one of the reasons he
decided to to run in 2019 was because of
what he was seeing was because of what
occurred in Charlottesville which was
devastating see that in our streets
in American in in America and he spoke
very clearly you saw you saw the op-ed
that he wrote when he saw that and so it
has always been something that's been
top of mind for him he spoke about it in
his inaugural speech uh you know the
soul of our nation and protecting our
democracy he spoke about it
on January 6 the anniversary of January
6th this past year you heard him speak
about this at in front of Independence
Hall or at Independence Hall outside of
Independence Hall to be more specific
where you know our democracy started if
you will and so this is a conversation
that he continues to have clearly we are
seeing an uptick a sad uptick of
rhetoric uh of political rhetoric coming
from uh really extreme Republicans uh in
office and also yes you know we saw this
violent awful horrific attack on Paul
Pelosi and so uh you know there are
reasons that he believed this time was
now to to to make sure that he spoke
directly to the American people again
and he has said this before this is
nothing new we are at an inflection
point these are not regular regular
normal times one more question and I
know we keep asking it but I'm going to
try it from a different angle I wonder
what the question is going to be I don't
know what I'm gonna happen the president
of the White House
um so I went back every president since
Bill Clinton has immediately after the
midterm election held a lengthy press
conference uh to talk about the results
to answer questions from reporters about
what it means for his presidency
um Ronald Reagan did it too
um and and just today you haven't yet
committed to holding a press conference
on the 9th does this mean that President
Biden is going to break with this
tradition look I again I'm not going to
go uh I'm not going to get far ahead of
of where we are currently I'm sure the
president will take your questions like
he does almost every day and that we
will address the elections the day after
election day and I'm just gonna leave it
there not gonna get ahead I
you know I'm sure that the president
again will uh will make his voice very
clear uh the day after election day and
I'll leave it there I understand the
question I appreciate the question and
I'm happy to answer it every time it's
asked okay thank you Kareem following up
on your comment that there's an alarming
number of Republicans who are saying
they're not going to accept election
results
does that mean President Biden thinks it
is a threat to democracy if somebody
votes Republican
no that's a that's a ridiculous question
no why is that a ridiculous question
because American people should have
their right to vote for whomever they
want the Voting is a sacred right it is
something that the president wants to
protect at at every turn and he has done
that he's taken actions to protect the
right to vote and uh and you see uh
Democrats in Congress also doing the
work to protect the right to vote we are
talking about Mega Maga uh Republican
officials who have been very clear about
this who who say who say uh you know
they are uh pro-police but then they are
also pro-insurrectionists that is you
cannot be pro-police and be pro pro
insurrectionist who also say they want
to defund the FBI that's a problem that
is a problem that we are seeing and who
I've said have been very clear that they
have they have been very clear about
pushing and peddling uh the big lie
peddling dangerous conspiracy theory and
so that's what we're talking about but
the American people have their they have
their right to make a decision on who
they want to represent them and they
should be allowed to do so okay in the
context of calling out election deniers
then is he going to call out Republicans
that deny election results and Democrats
that deny it doesn't matter it doesn't
matter if there's a d or an R after your
call out any rhetoric uh that is that
that leads to potentially political
violence or that cause it's political
violence for political violence that is
a problem the president has always
always condemned uh political violence
it doesn't matter again if you're a
Republican and independent or a Democrat
so President Biden thinks democracy can
survive even if Democrats are not in
charge of Congress the president is
optimistic he is an optimistic you know
this Peter he's an optimistic person and
he understands that is majority of the
Americans out there who do not believe
in election and denying an election who
believe in actually protecting our
democracy there are majority of
Americans who believe in strengthening
our democracy and that's what we see but
the president as the President of the
United States he believes it is his it
is his duty is his responsibility to
call out this rhetoric and that's what
he's going to continue to do go ahead
thanks I'm on the election in Brazil has
the U.S have U.S officials made any
Outreach to bolsonaro to try and
encourage him to accept the results of
that election and for that transition
process
so I'll uh don't have any calls to reach
to read out to you on any conversation
with uh with uh bolsonaro but we are
glad to see that President bolsonaro
acknowledged the results of the election
and has allowed the transition process
to begin the Brazilian electoral
Authority has made the determination of
who won the free and fair election and
that it and that is president-elect uh
Lula the the will of the people of
Brazil should be respected and that's
what we believe and any comment on the
election Israel and the Netanyahu
appears to be incredible victory yeah
don't want to get ahead of uh ahead of
that we are pleased to see such strong
voter turnout for this election it is
too early to to speculate as you know on
the exact composition of the next
governing Coalition until all the votes
are counted I know we've all seen the
exit polls we look forward to continuing
to work with the Israeli government on
our shared interest and value so I'll
leave it there
given the number of Republicans who have
said they they won't accept the results
and just the unpredictability of this
election compared to others is the White
House doing any contingency planning for
election night or the day after uh just
people not accepting results if violence
breaks out
um how are you guys thinking about that
so A couple of things I've been asked
about this before and I I want to be
clear uh and and say this again
Americans should feel free safe they
should feel safe
going to the polls they should and so
this Administration has taken the issue
of of threats uh to the safety of Voters
and election officials seriously since
day one and the federal government has
been working alongside state and local
election officials and law enforcement
to take the necessary steps to keep
people safe and uh and again their
agencies across the across the
government that is working on that every
day
just want to clarify if we're going to
be hearing something new tonight it
sounded like you were saying that he'll
be repeating what he said before it just
needs to be he needs to say it again is
that right or should we expect something
different from what he's been saying
what he said on September 1st so the
lawyers have have been very clear with
me that I cannot get into uh previewing
the speech or get into what the
president's going to talk about I'm just
giving you a little bit of what he has
said in the past and why this moment is
very important but I'm not going to go
into details of the speech and one other
questions taught just now the
president's been talking about
highlighting the differences between
Republicans and Democrats what issues do
you see as having the most potential for
agreement in the next couple degrees
I'm not going to get into hypotheticals
what I can say right now is as we have
been for the past several months uh is
what's uh what's at stake and the
choices that the American people are
going are going to have to make again
I'm not going to get into uh any uh
elections or um you know politics from
here but again the president has been
very very clear so has the vice
president so has the first lady so has
the second gentleman so has cabinet
secretaries have been very clear about
what's at stake and what we have been
able to deliver for the American people
and what we will continue to do
regardless of any outcome good Ben Anita
Dunn said this morning that after the
midterms the White House's priority for
the lame duck session of Congress would
be keeping the government funded and
providing additional Ukrainian covet Aid
what about protecting same-sex marriage
where does that fall in the president
that so as you know if you know the
president's history when it comes to the
lgbtq plus Community this is uh this is
a this is an issue that has been a
priority for him and will continue to be
I don't have anything to lay out on
Congressional uh priorities at this time
but when it comes to marriage equality
when it comes to protecting
the community he is that this is
something that he's been a strong voice
for a strong Ally and has delivered on
will you be pushing for that in the lame
duck session again I'm not going to get
into what he's any Congressional
priorities at this time I'm just saying
that his his history his record speaks
for itself
good Nadia thank you uh the
Administration has been leading the
efforts at the U.N today to expel Iran
from the U.N Commission on the status of
women can you just talk us through this
decision and we expect uh also that you
will push for more for explaining Iran
from International organizations
let folks get up
for a second I know people have to
gather
you're going to the event
it's clear I know I know Kelly you're
always very sensitive to that because
people are watching
and it's okay I'm not that sense of it
um
thank you
all right my friends oh um so Nadia on
your question look
um
as it relates to uh what we see the
actions that we have seen uh the Iranian
government take on
um on on um the horrible actions that
they've they've taken on protesters
women who are bravely seeking to uh
seeking to uh to speak for uh for their
basic rights we have been very clear the
president has spoken against that he has
he has called out and lifted up uh the
the brave women and and citizens of Iran
for doing that for being out there and
and speaking out and uh and he's called
out the Iranian government and we have
uh Accord across the past several weeks
laid out just what we have been doing to
make sure that we hold Iran into account
in the last week the United States the
European Union and Canada have
sanctioned more Iranian officials for
the ongoing Crackdown that we've been
seeing the violent Crackdown that we
have seen and I think you saw the
reports more than 200 people have died
in Iran because of because they have
been protesting we have hosted a new end
dialogue with the special
a special
special situation on of human rights in
Iran welcome The Joint statement by
women foreign ministers on events in
Iran and supported Germany's
recalibration of their Iran policy we
welcome civil society's call for the
immediate expulsion of the Islamic
Republic from the U.N Commission on the
status of women the U.S government will
take action to ensure Iran is is removed
to your question women and men in Iran
must have the right to freedom of
expression and assembly that is
something that the president believes
that is something that this
Administration believes women should be
able to wear what they want free from
violence or harassment Iran must end its
use of violence against its own citizens
simply for exercising their fundamental
freedoms their basic rights until Iran
changes its Behavior the United States
will continue to impose cost and hold
accountable Iranian officials and
entities that are responsible for
employing violence to suppress protests
civil civil society and women's rights
another one on
an Iranian delegation is restricted to
meet in Austria with the iaea this week
curious if the administration if the U.S
is going to have any sort of role in
that and what it says in your view with
uh you know the sort of stalemate that's
emerged in the larger nuclear talks so I
don't have anything to share on that
particular uh I iaea visit
um so clearly that's something that we
will we recommend uh we welcome I should
say not recommend uh but don't have
anything else to share beyond beyond
that is sort of a movement one way or
another I just want to talk to the team
before I'm I make any uh statement on
that or take any position
good thanks uh on your on what you said
about the president saying that he's
concerned about Republicans who have
refused to say that they will accept the
election results
does he does the president think that
those refusals will create political
violence will lead to political violence
while he's speaking because he wants to
make sure that it's he's loud and clear
um and I want to make be very careful
because I want to don't want to go into
uh go into anything that he might say
tonight or into his speech uh that what
we're seeing these are not normal times
right this is an inflection point uh
that it is important as the President of
the United States to speak out uh
against the against what he's seeing
against this rhetoric against political
violence uh and um look you know it is
it is an important time in in our in our
history and uh you know as I've
mentioned before this is one of the
reasons why this President uh decided to
uh to run for this very office
um you know I look I don't want to get
into hypotheticals of what may happen
but what the president believes is that
what he is seeing and what we are
hearing from Maga Republican official
extreme Republican officials who say
that they are not going to accept this
election is is a threat to our democracy
and so I'll just leave it there
green
um about tonight but beyond tonight the
president is looking for this speech
tonight to kind of quell some of the
reactions and the the upset these
political upsets happening but there's
more to it than that what's next beyond
the speech you know because on the hill
they're talking about you know Capital
police can't really secure a lot of the
leaders who are in need of help what's
next beyond the speech so when it comes
to the protection of leaders to the kind
of the lacks part of your of your
question there I don't want to get into
commenting on security related matters
that is something that we are very
sensitive to and want to be very Mindful
and careful here so anything that's
related to you know individual safety at
the Capitol that goes to the capital
police on uh and on even on any
questions of the speaker's security I
know that has been uh something that
folks have been asking but again for a
variety of reasons we're just not going
to comment on security related matters
or discuss issues related to the
speaker's security or any member
security this is a subject that's best
left for the Capitol Police look this is
the president understand that there's a
lot of work to do this is on your first
part of the question this is why you've
heard him talk about protecting our
democracy strengthening our democracy
and uh you know and what we the work
that we need to continue to do several
times I've listed out the many times
that he and I'm sure I've missed one or
two the many times that he's had this
very uh this very kind of conversation
given this very these types of remarks
I'm not going to again get into what
he's going to say I'm going to let the
president speak for himself but again
this is an inflection point this is an
inflection point
um in our in our in our country's
history and there is a choice that the
that Americans are going to have to make
so and just surmising what you're saying
this there is other pieces Beyond just
the speech tonight to help
change the dynamic of this inflection
point from going into a negative again I
I cannot get into anything specific that
he's going to say I did mention at the
top at the top that one of the things
that the president implemented very
early on back in June of 2021 as we talk
about security and safety it is the
national strategy for countering
domestic terrorism which is something
that the president put out and did over
a year ago so those are some actions
that he was he did take lastly on the
Supreme Court
um affirmative action
um in education in the at the admissions
process
but if there's a roll back there are
tentacles that could go into so many
other spaces how is the White House
prepared in case there is because we've
seen rollbacks already yeah
look the president has been very clear
about what's at stake right affirmative
action we saw Roe uh the decision on Roe
and how
um you know a constitutional right that
was around for almost 50 years was taken
away freedoms have been taken away from
women just across millions of women
across the country he's been very clear
voting rights is going to be is that is
is at stake marriage equality is at
stake the president has listed that out
and has been very clear and this kind of
goes to what we're talking about today
and what we have been talking about for
the past several weeks several months
which is so much is at stake so much is
at stake for the American people when
you think about our freedoms when you
think about our rights this is what the
president has been trying to say and has
been saying is that's why there's a
choice to be made this is why you know
the work that he's been doing in
Congressional Democrats have been so
important because we are we are fighting
for the freedom of Americans we are
fighting for the rights of Americans we
understand not just our role here but
our role globally I was just asked
but Nadia just asked me about Iran and
what we what the president has said
about that about protesters in Iran
women who are fighting for their rights
civilians who are fighting for their
right and the violent Crackdown that
we're seeing there so the president
understand his role more globally as
well so we're going to keep talking keep
talking about this we're going to make
sure that we're doing everything that we
can with Congressional Democrats to see
to make sure that we're protecting the
rights of of Americans but again there
is a choice to be to be made
yeah thank you uh Jen saki said from
that podium in summer of 2021 quote we
are flagging problematic posts for
Facebook that spread disinformation uh
can you tell us whether the White House
is still flagging social media posts for
this information and are you submitting
those to Facebook through a special
portal
um can you say a little bit more
yeah there was a reporting in The
Intercept about
opportunities for the federal government
to identify for social media companies
different posts that contains what was
perceived as misinformation about the
origins of covid the vaccine other
things as well you know such as Ukraine
or the US withdrawal from Afghanistan
yeah so um look I'll say this um the the
administration
um the bite Administration remains fully
uh committed to our mission to protect
the security and resilience of our um of
of our you know elections and Safeguard
election infrastructure that includes
combat combating disinformation that is
something that we are committed to
um you know we work to protect that uh
protect Americans from disinformation
that threatens the Homeland including
malicious efforts spread by Foreign
adverse
adversaries
adversaries sorry pardon me began before
the disinformation governance board was
established in fact some of that work
began before this Administration so I
you know I want I want to be very clear
that cross-agency work continues to this
day I don't want to don't want to get
ahead of of anything else this is a
Department of Homeland Security so I
would refer you to them so you are
flagging uh misinformation I don't have
anything more than to add this is a
Department of Homeland Security that I
refer to does the White House
participate in the secret government
censorship portal though I think that
was part of the question is the White
House submit examples of disinformation
and misinformation for Facebook to
censor through this portal no
um I wanted to follow up because you've
spoken at length about the threat that
those who deny documented truth about
our elections pose and some critics have
raised the soap so I want to see if you
can maybe Square the president's current
rhetoric when it comes to elections with
what he said in January during a press
conference when he said of those
midterms quote the increase in the
prospect of them being illegitimate is
in proportion to not being able to get
those reforms passed obviously those
voting reforms did not pass Congress so
is he confident that the coming midterms
are going to be legit how are those two
things congruent yeah this is something
that you're talking about that Jen Jen
reference
no the the president said oh right right
but I think you asked did you ask Jen
this question as well
okay
um so uh so just to clear this up
because I think you've asked me this
question before uh jensaki briefed the
following day after this press
conference and answered that that
question that you asked about the
president in his statement from the
press conference the day before and she
said I talked to the president about
this last about this last night and this
morning he was not intending to cast out
on the legitimacy of the 2020 election
he was actually attempting to make the
opposite point which is that in 2020
despite covid despite many attempts to
suppress the vote a record number of
Voters Democrats and Republicans
Independents to tuned turned out in the
face of a pandemic and we saw that with
our very own eyes and you all reported
this and election officials made sure
they would vote and have those votes
counted and this is how jensaki
responded to your very question so those
voting forms did not pass Congress the
president is expecting from elections to
be legitimate say that again so even
though his preferred voting reforms did
not pass Congress the president is
expecting that the coming midterm
elections will be legitimate yes yes
that is that is a yes
to the agreement between the Ethiopian
federal government and the Thai Korean
authorities in South Africa
a couple lines for you there um so as
you know the the United States we are we
are committed to the unity sovereignty
and territorial Integrity of Ethiopia we
seek peace and stability in Ethiopia to
build upon the long-standing strong
partnership between our governments and
people the United States commends the
African Union panel on their
extraordinary leadership to determine
efforts to facilitate talks as well as
the work of the African Union commission
South Africa who hosted and and
international partner Partners the
United Nations the government the
intergovernmental Authority on
development the United the United States
remains committed to supporting this
African union-led process as it
continues and to partnering to ensure it
brings a lasting peace to Ethiopia and
that is something that we are committed
we're going to continue back Courtney I
want to ask about student loan relief
um
excuse me have you approved or is it the
education department in the process of
approving anything or the applications
for Relief conditionally so I'm sorry
can you speak up just a little bit Yeah
I want to ask about student loan really
are you or the education department in
the process of approving any of the
applications that you've collected
conditionally or so that you're ready if
there is a change in the court pause on
Distributing relief so we're continuing
to receive and process applications for
debt relief that is what we have been
doing for the past two weeks now I
believe and we're continuing to
encourage eligible borrowers to apply
for Relief at studentaid.gov that is
something that that is the Outreach that
we are continuing to do from here and
clearly from the Department of Education
I should say from the Department of
Education remember the eighth circuits
order does not reverse the lower Court's
dismissal of the case or suggest that
the case has Merit it merely prevents
debt from being discharged until the
court makes a decision but we're going
to continue to to again collect the
information and the process and process
the applications we're going to continue
to encourage people who are eligible to
do that uh and and we will be at the
ready when the time comes and I another
question of the IRS I know that
secretary Yellen just appointed someone
to temporarily leave while the president
considers who to nominate for
commissioner will the president be
meeting with the acting commissioner
will be talking at all with him or
secretary Ellen's team given that IRS
reform is such a big part of your agenda
I don't have any any meetings to preview
or anything to lay out clearly that is
something that's under uh secretary
yellin's purview and so I would I would
just refer to her if you have any
questions specifically to to uh to the
acting
thank you Corrine I wanted to ask about
the president's reaction to the attack
on Paul Pelosi you spent a lot of time
in more informal settings with the
president on Air Force One in between
public appearances can you tell us
how he reacted as more details came out
about the attack on Buffalo season
um you know
the president spoke for himself and
and a pretty open book and he um you
know he speaks from his our heart and so
I think what you heard from him directly
is exactly what we all hear when he's
not in front of you or in front of a
camera I don't think there's any uh
there's not any difference this was a
horrific attack and as I mentioned the
president spoke to the speaker on on
Friday he spoke to this again on
Saturday
and uh you know he's relieved to know
that he's expected to recover as we have
said the president is praying for the
speaker and her family and for Paul
Pelosi
um you know this is a again a horrific
what we saw was horrific and it is
political violence as we're hearing the
reports and it has no place in our
political discourse but uh I'm not going
to to get into any more specifics on
private conversations that I have with
the president can you tell us a little
bit more about how her react is he as he
heard about jokes that prominent
Republicans have made about the attack
look um
you know the president spoke to to um to
spoke to the political violence
specifically uh to to the speaker's
husband yesterday so I will leave his
I'll leave it to that I will refer you
to what the president said don't have
anything more to to add the president is
going to uh
speak tonight and I'm not just I'm just
not going to get into details on what he
will say but of course this is something
that the president condemns he condemns
all types of political violence there is
no place in the in in politics no place
across the country uh for it and he's
going to continue to condemn that and
I'm going to let you all hear from the
president directly himself I think I'm
being called to leave that's this Podium
and um hopefully I see you guys in New
Mexico and California thanks guys
everywhere you don't have